tipper walk is taking over this game
[Music]
[Applause]
Walker willing the Hornets back into
this one there's a bad drive shots go
big time players make big time play
you just said hey you know what I got to
get to the basket I got my first step is
deadly he's able to blow right by him
now he can just get to the basket and
finish with his elevation
[Applause]
for Durant
durant is dancing in France
menacing the crowd
everywhere
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and be thinking about it there it is for
the tie JoEllen beat nothing short of
magnificent tonight as the Sixers win it
by one 133 to 132 Rose gets inside puts
up a tough shot and hits it anyway
looks awfully great talent 2011 MVP
ropes
everybody just streams out of the floor
to greet him showing respect
James attacking Gibson
43 for James putting his head down same
old story taking the contact and
finished they get it to cricket has been
large tonight
Griffin drifting
[Applause]
really
is it ever
he's got 14 of 2452 in the game
the NBA record 14 threes